[Music]
so thank you for fitting the house I am
really impressed that tensorflow is is
getting so much attention but I think
the technology deserves it so I'm happy
about that
so today yesterday we built a neural
network for recognizing handwritten
digits and we went to Daniel networks
and convolutional neural networks and
today I hope to build with you another
kind of network the recurrent neural
network so let's go a couple of
reminders from yesterday you remember we
started with this initial one layer
neural network and I need to I need you
to remember the formula for one layer of
the neural network because we will be
using it so this is we were reading in
pixels but it works for any input vector
of course and you remember we said that
the neuron do weighted sums of all of
their inputs they added bias and they
feed that through some activation
function your softmax it can be another
function is just a function value in
value out but usually in Murrell
networks it's a nonlinear function and
we wrote this this one layer neural
network using a matrix multiply lavalla
we sing all that as this formula and you
remember we did this not for just one
image but we actually wrote this formula
processing 100 images at the time so in
X we have a batch of images a whole
batch 100 images and then x times W are
all the weighted sum for our neurons we
have the biases we see that through our
activation function
and we obtain a batch of predictions so
in our case since we were classifying
handwritten digits those predictions or
10 numbers which are the probabilities
of these digits being
0 a 1 a 2 a 3 and so on and shall we
obtain those probabilities of the
outputs of our 10 neuron ok so whenever
you see this formula we will see it
again a lot today
you think one layer of a neural network
ok and then also what I need you to
remember is that once we get our output
from the neural network the way we train
it is that we give it example it
produces some prediction and then we say
no no no that's not what we wanted this
is what you should predict we give it
the correct answer and to do that we
have to encode this correct answer in a
similar format so it's call it's very
you know basic type of encoding it's
called one hot encoding and basically
here if we have 10 categories specifying
one answer category means encoding it as
10 zeros with just one one someone in
the middle and one index of the one here
is at index 6 means that the correct
answer was a 6 ok so in this shape it
becomes possible to compute a distance
between what the network predicts and
what we know to be true and so in that
distance we call that our error function
or sometimes it's called the loss
function that's what we use to guide our
training so during training we give it
an example produces an output we say no
no that's not solving what we wanted
compute the distance between what the
network says and what we know to be true
and from that distance we derive the
gradient and then we follow the gradient
and that modifies the weights and biases
and that's what the training is about ok
so
now let's look at this neural network so
it should look familiar
it's as extra as an input it has a
middle layer using the hyperbolic
tangent as an activation function so
we've seen the sigmoid last time which
is the let's say that you know the
simplest possible function going from
zero to one continuously the hyperbolic
tangent is the simplest possible
function going from minus 1 to 1
continuously it's just the sigmoid
shifted and then a second layer which is
a soft max layer so that we read
something else but the specificity is
here that the output of this
intermediate green layer is actually fed
back in the next time step in the inputs
so the real input into one cell of a
recurrent neural network is the input
concatenated to the output of the inner
layer from the previous step and we call
it the coldest of the state so it's
actually a state machine you feed it
inputs it produces outputs but it you
also feed it a state it produces an
output stage which you feed back in in
the next time step and that's why it's
called a recurrent neural network is
because it it is a point on time
sequences at each step in time you feed
in one input vector concatenated to the
previous state turn the crank once that
produces some outputs from this middle
layer as well as a result and you feed
that back as the new input stage for the
next X input which you have in your
sequence so it can be represented here
there as I'm showing you the neurons
inside but here is basically the API of
one recurrent neural network cell it has
an input it has an output which you then
usually feed into a softmax layer to
make sense of it to produce
predictions I mean probabilities and it
has an input stage that produces an
output say that you loop back in as the
input state that's the state machine
part okay so now oh yes and the
parameter for this is the internal size
of this middle layer that's what is
adjustable usually your input is
whatever your input is and your output
is whatever you're trying to predict so
those are not adjustable parameters also
here it is written in equations again
the the input is the real input at time
t concatenated to the previous state
then we see that through here you should
recognize one layer of a neural network
you should recognize this this formula
using the hyperbolic tangent as an
activation function so I put it over
there and this produces an output HT
which is both used as our new state and
as the output that will be set into the
softmax layer to actually produce a
vector of probabilities between 0 and 1
ok so now how do you train this thing
so typically this is used for natural
language processing for instance so a
typical input will be a character and a
character will be again one hot encoded
into let's say a 100 component vector if
we are using we will be using here an
alphabet of 100 possible characters so
one character is encoded into a 100
element vector as 100 for 99 zeros and a
one at the ASCII index of that character
so we put a character in we propagate
through the neural networks we propagate
through the soft wax layer we obtain the
correct
as an output if that is not the
character we wanted well
we compute the difference between what
he said and what we know to be true and
use retro propagation to call to fix the
weights and biases inside of the cell to
get better results
that's very classical training but what
if the result was wrong not because the
weights and biases inside of the cell
were wrong but because the input the
state input H minus one was wrong that
input is a constant in this problem but
it's not much you can do about it so
here we're stuck
what is the solution well the solution
is to replicate this cell and now if you
if you so this is a replica it's reusing
the exact same weight okay now let's see
the output y1 is bad I said I don't know
no that's not it this was the correct
output and training so I know what the
correct output is supposed to be so from
that I compute the error the gradient I
retro propagate I can fix the weights
and biases in the cells to get a better
output and if needed I can fix the
weights and biases to get a better h0
the state flowing between those two
stages of the cell so now I have a
handle on at least h0 I still have no
handle at all h minus 1 if it is H minus
1 that was wrong there is nothing I can
do so that is how you train neural
recurrent neural networks you have to
unroll them across a certain length and
give them a sequence of let's say
characters it will produce a sequence of
output characters if you are training
here you know what the answer was
supposed to be so you use that to
computer you know your error function do
your retro propagation adjust the
weights and biases and it will work to a
certain extent
what expect oh yes
small detail if you want to go deep you
can actually stack the cells why well
two cells stacked like this the the API
remains the same it's there is still an
input it's still an output that feeds
into the softmax layer and there is
still an input state and an output stage
that you feed back it's just that the
output stage now is slightly bigger so
that's how you go deep in regular neural
network you stack those cells and that
becomes a new cell which still has input
output input stage output stage and of
course you unroll it so let's take this
sentence let's say now we use not
characters but words as our input of
course there are technical problems
doing that a typical alphabet is maybe
100 characters a typical vocabulary is
around 30,000 words so here 100 coding
gives you a vector of 30,000 components
for each word it's a bit heavy I won't
go into the details of how you handle
that it's called embedding whatever
let's just assume that we we solve this
problem so we have this sentence Michael
was born in Paris blah blah blah blah
blah and at the end we have his mother
tongue is so if we train this model on
English probably it will have figured
out that his his mother song is is
followed by the name of the language
like English German Russian something
here however the correct answer is
French because this guy was born in
France so let's imagine that we we see
again we have unrolled this neural
network over let's say 30 words or let's
say ten words ten words and at the end
we have his mother tongue is and we are
asking the network to predict what is
the next word and the network says
English so now what we want to do is put
on the outputs a centre that
blah blah blah his mother tongue is
French and Jew retro propagation but for
this to work the beginning of the
sentence the the part where the
information about parish and where he is
born is has to be part of that that
example and that example is longer than
n-word which is our unrolled size there
is simply no way whatsoever of signal of
putting that correct example was correct
output into a network that we unrolled
over only 10 words because the distance
is more than 10 and that's a fundamental
limitation if you want to capture this
information this behavior that if he was
born in France probably his mother
languages is French you will have to
unroll this network over a long enough
sequence to be able to input this full
example into it and if you do that you
will probably unroll it here over how
many 50 words and like that if you do
that the problem is that you end up with
a very deep neural network yesterday we
see we see neural networks of five
layers the big ones like Inception and
so on or 40 50 60 70 layers you see you
know we have three examples and we
already see that we should be going to
50 or 100 layers just to solve this so
in a recurrent neural networks you
always end up using very deep neural
networks and when I say deep is because
you know the the state signal has to go
through all those cells and remember in
each cell the state signal is
concatenated to the input to go through
a neural network layer produces a new
state which goes to the next cell that
is concurrent to the input goes through
another neural network layer so from
here to the end which others at least
one neural network layer per cell that's
Hawaii
deep neural networks have a technical
problem they tend not to converge when
you train them I won't go into the
mathematical details it's called the
vanishing gradient problem basically
your gradient becomes zero and since you
use your gradient to go forward that's a
bit of a problem so the solution was
invented I won't go into the
mathematical explanations of why the
solution works I just want you to
understand how it works so would you
learn explanation using the arrow soup
of the diagram on the left or the
incomprehensible equations on the right
which ones do you prefer hello
you know I'm a developer and those
equations they look a little bit like
codes and they're you know and I do code
sorry but on the arrows you see at least
one thing so I'll do some hands what you
mean waving mathematics here again you
see that is the state is actually split
in two you have the H State in the sea
State and the sea line there is actually
configured in such a way that the
network can decide to persist
information on it to read it unchanged
from iteration to iteration and that is
somehow what explains that it initially
line up many of those since it has the
possibility of reading some part of the
state unchanged it goes around those
vanishing gradients problems end of hand
waving mathematics so but still let's
see how it works in practice and
actually it's based on a concept of
gauge so again we concatenate the inner
real inputs to the state from the
previous step and we compute three you
recognize the formulas neural network
later
okay the Sigma is for the sigmoid
activation function so the Sigma outputs
values between 0 and 1 and we call those
gates because we will actually be
multiplying these numbers to another
vector to get it you know if you
multiply something by a very small value
there is not much that goes through if
you multiply something by something that
is close to 1 almost all of the
information goes to so that's how we
will be using them now
we are done our input becomes well we
have to size adapt our input I put on
the side the sizes of all the vectors we
are working with that just to tell you
that there is nothing to see there
inside of the cell everything is of size
n that's the parameter that you decide
as the size of yourself okay
but our input there they are not there
what they are so we first need one
neural network layer to adapt the size
of our inputs to size n so that becomes
our new input engine and now the C Line
the way you read this is that this is a
kind of memory so the new state of the
memory is the old state of the memory
without what we chose to forget we
multiplied by this forget gate this is a
series of numbers between 0 and 1 plus
what we chose to remember from our new
input that's the way to read it so these
we multiply our new input by the update
gate again numbers between 0 and 1 that
shows which part of the information we
want to retain from this input into our
internal memory and then our new state
is simply the memory the the hyperbolic
tangent here that's not a neural network
layer that's just a size adaptation to
put it between minus 1 and 1 so it's
basically the memory cell multiplied by
the result gate so here we choose what
part of our internal memory we want to
expose to the outside as a result so
that's the you know physical
interpretation of these equations we
have those three gates we size adapt our
input and then the new memory is the old
memory - what we want to forget plus
what we want to remember from this from
the input and the result is this memory
cell modulo what we want to actually
expose as an output at that step okay
and now this HD will actually become
part of the new state and also drive the
softmax layer if we add a softmax layer
which is represented here by this yellow
circle we usually represent the softmax
later as external to a cell so this is
called an LS pm and this was invented
specifically to make recurrent neural
networks work and to solve this death
problem that if you were unrolling over
a large sequence they tended not to
converge you will have to believe me on
the mathematics with this they converge
but you will have to say I'm sure
someone noticed that this choice of
equations and this choice of arrows was
somehow arbitrary
I mean why point them here and not there
many combinations exist lots of
different variations of those Orang n
cells have been devised and someone
published a paper a recap paper where he
tested all of them and found them to do
all exactly the same thing so in the end
the one we use is called the group and I
won't go into the details is basically a
cheaper lsdm did here are the equations
not very different same API but only two
gates
instead of three gates and each gate has
weights and biases so we save a part of
our computational cycle not computing
those Siraj equation biases
okay so we will use the group and now
let's implement you know network that
does a language model so we will be
training on sequences of characters and
when I say language model it's actually
a network that we will use to predict
will trainee to predict what the next
character is like here st. job I will
teach it to produce the same sequence
shifted by one so actually I will teach
it to understand that the next character
should be an N because this is st. John
so how do we do that
in tensorflow
now I'm using a higher level API of
contra flow than what I have been using
yesterday I just call three cells that
creates a GRU cell and I call this
higher level because you've seen this
GRU cell has actually a couple of neural
network layers inside it has two gates
that are please two layers so it has a
host of ways and biases which are
actually defined in the background when
I call this that's why it's a higher
level API it does its own ways and by us
the declarations in the background now I
said we want to go deep so let's stack
this cell three high that's how we do
deep recurrent neural networks there is
a temporal call for that it's called
meet multi errand and cell you give it a
cell you say how many times you want to
stack it and that gives you another cell
because we have seen already that these
three stacked cells actually have the
same API as oneself you can use it as a
new cell and now we need to unroll this
for that we call intensive for this
dynamic RNN function which is a bit of
magic and that's what will unroll this
sequence so how many times you don't see
it in the parameters because it's
actually specified in the shape of the
input tensor X okay if this input tensor
has eight or let's say sir
characters in it it will be unrolled
over the sequence of 30 characters and
actually the little part of magic with
its magic that we will not be using it
here but this dynamic Aaron what it can
do also remember that we will be
training this on batches as always
always turn on batches so in this case
all my batches will be sequences of the
same size that's the case in my model in
different in other models I might not
have sequences of the same size dynamic
error none can handle that if you pass
it a batch of sequences even if they are
not of the same size alongside that you
pass the actual sizes and it will for
each sentence in the batch under all
your network the correct number of times
and then also pass the output from the
correct stage it's super helpful will
not be using it here because all of our
series you know sequences have the same
size but that is super helpful all right
so now we need to implement our softmax
layer from those H double second 0 to H
second 8 well basically the outputs at
the bottom we know how to do is a flux
layer ok but here since we have unrolled
remember each stack here is a copy of
the previous one we are sharing the
waste so on the on the softmax side we
have to share the weight as well so we
could do this using the the 10 to the 80
is you know define one softmax layer and
then for the next one : api that we
treat the weight of the previous one
area and we uses them and that's so
complicated here actually there is a
little hack that you can use remember we
are always training on batches ok
so this will be taking a batch of
sequences out putting a batch of
sequences each sequence is a sequence of
characters so what is the difference
between having let's say eight softmax
cells that each process a batch of 100
characters or having just one that
processes 800 of them that's the same
thing let's just do one and we will put
all of those outputs in the same bag and
just use that one cell anyway we were
supposed to be sharing the weight so
defining just one seller is a very good
way of doing that so that's what I do
with my reshape operation there I take
all of those outputs and and and you
have to remember that there is a batch
of output on each of those arrows and I
put them in the same bag feed them
through just one softmax layer and then
I will reshape them back into the
correct shape to chew on to finish again
using the higher-level api's intent flow
okay so when I call linear that just
that does just the weight itself one
layer and it computes simply the
weighted sums no oxidation function and
then I call softmax and that applies the
softmax activation function and linear
again defines the weights and biases in
the background that's why I call it a
higher-level function and now I'm ready
to compute my loss function and derive
it and actually train the network it's
just as complicated to understand how
recurrent neural networks work and it's
just as complicated to actually feed
them data correctly you see lots of
adults so we will have to do quite a bit
of plumbing to make this happen let's
try to get our inputs and outputs right
okay so we will be inputting sequences
of characters by batches so my input is
a
catch of sequences the sequence length
they have that I have chosen is
searching I will be unrolling over 30
characters usually on the diagrams I
only represent eight of them because 30
would not fit on my slide but in the
code it was 30 now I need to one hut
encode them so I'm adding a new size
each character becomes a vector of 100
components because I am working with an
alphabet of 100 possible characters so
now it's batch size sequence lines and
alpha size those are my actual input my
state again I have a batch of state
since I'm feeding in a batch of inputs I
will produce a batch of output state and
they state each of those state vectors
is of course of size n cell size
whatever cell size I have chosen to use
remember each cell has this one
configuration parameter which is it
internal size but since I have stacked
those cells three high it will actually
the the actual output state here will be
three times the sell-side okay we are
ready to write this model so I define a
placeholder for my input sequences a
batch of sequences of size sequence
length I want how to encode them which
is why I'm adding a new size to
dispenser which is the size of my
alphabet again each character becomes a
vector of 100 components to be really
precise my alpha sorry is 98 so
ninety-eight components I'm working with
an alphabet of 98 characters here I need
to define a place folder for my correct
answers and actually the correct answers
are very easy to obtain here I'm just
teaching it to output the same sequence
shifted by one so basically to predict
what the last character will be so again
the correct answers will be a batch of
sequences of 30 characters which I want
how to encode
I need a placeholder also for my input
state and we have seen that the batch of
input space we have seen that the input
state is made of three of those internal
vectors so that three times cell size
and now I'm ready to write my model so
the model is what was here okay that's
the model this model with this little
trick that we have seen before this
model at the output of its softmax layer
actually produces an output that is
batch size x sequence lines you remember
we put all the characters from the
batches and from the different stages of
the unrolled sequence in the same bag
and now to determine character from
those probabilities I use Arg max why
because each of those vectors is you
know 100 components with probabilities
or ik max is a function that gives me
the index of the biggest number in this
vector so in the index in this vector is
actually asking code of the character
that that has been predicted so these
are my predictions now in ASCII encoding
in characters and I just need to reshape
them back to have again a batch of
sequences of 30 predicted characters and
now I'm ready to input to give my loss
to an optimizer and asks tensorflow
to optimize to actually train line
network so this is the step as yesterday
with this loss tensor so compute the
gradient from this gradient it can sorry
and this loss is of course the
difference between the sequence of
characters that was predicted and the
sequence of characters that I wanted to
predict
this difference becomes a loss that loss
derived becomes a gradient we take a
small step along this gradient which is
actually in the space of whites and
biases so taking a small step means we
modify slightly our weights and biases
and continue that's the training one
last little gotcha so we have to take
our input text and actually cut it up in
those sequences of 30 characters so
initially I saw it well as easy you know
you take a piece of text how do you cut
it up in sequences of characters well
you cut and cut and cut and cut and then
you need a batch of them you take the
first 100 sequences you have and you put
that in a batch that did not work why
let's see here that's my first batch
let's see the first sequence in the
batch the quick you know what that is
going to be the quick brown fox
something
well when my noodle network processes
the quick
it also outputs an output state and in
the next iteration that output state
will become the input stage for the next
sequence if I want this to be correct
that input state must correspond to the
continuation of the quick brown fox and
so on which means that the sentence has
to continue over all of the first slots
of all of my batches it's a non
completely trivial way of batching here
you cut up your text in batches in
sequences but the way to batch them
together since you have to pass the
correct state at each stage is that the
beginning of the text has to be split
across the first item in the batches and
then from some point far far far later
in the text you can start filling the
second line of the batches it's just
lumping I wrote for you the five lines
of code that does this
it's five lines I spent four hours doing
it including tests yes I I don't do
arithmetic it's it's a full of modules
and divides and I wrote unit tests and a
hackett until the unit test passed
it's called test-driven debugging sorry
test-driven development
that's what developers do all right so
yeah small dots on the batching but
whatever
just use the code on this is not
actually important just use use the the
function that will cut up the text
correctly for you and you're ready to
train and this is actually the full code
of this neural network on one slide so
let's go through this again a
placeholder for my input sequences I
want her to encode them I'm actually
including inputting sequences of
characters okay and and and all the
people with cameras this is on github
and the github legal is on the last
slide so please take pictures my twitter
handle is is over there tweet them but
then you will you will be able to go and
github and actually retrieve this then
my expected output y underscore again I
define a placeholder for them I will
need to feed them during training and
the first thing I do is add a high one
hot encoder I will also need and this is
different from normal neural network I
will also need a placeholder for my
input States
remember RNN have an input input and
input state to input now I'm ready to
write my model so I chose the blue cell
I stack it three high and I unroll it as
many times as X has component in it so
here my unroll size is sequence length
and that's absurd it I chose 30
characters as the unroll size of my
recurrent neural network I do my little
trick with the softmax so I can
implement one softmax node I see the
output through my softmax node here I
apply org max to retrieve from the
softmax probably
he's the highest probability and that
the character I'm predicting I reshape
this back to have a batch of predicted
sequences also somewhere in the middle
in there
I have those probabilities I take those
probabilities and I compute the distance
between what it says and what I wanted
that's my loss I give my loss to the
optimizer I obtain a training step in
this training step is actually that
gradient which is computed on this batch
of Australian characters and which if I
follow it by a little step will modify
my weapon biases and bring me to
somewhere where this network works
better when it has a smaller error
function and now my training loop you
will you will see this is very familiar
to what we had previously we use this
magic blundering function that I gave
you to load sequences of characters in
the correct way and once I have a
sequence of characters
I run session dot run of my training
step I have to give in the input
characters I have to give it the
expected output and since this is a
recurrent neural network I have to give
it the input state this will give me an
output state and you see the magic line
why this is a regular neural network
that's the last line there in the read
input state becomes sorry the output
state becomes the new interest rate
that's why it's recurrent we are passing
the state round all right so we are done
with Delta regular neural networking now
we want to actually train it so let's go
to a demo I will be training this on the
complete works of William Shakespeare
that's not quite big data the complete
works of William Shakespeare are five
megabytes yes that puts things in
perspective he but it's good stuff
so in here we see he's it's training on
sequences so here are those sequences of
30 characters and here is a batch of
them it's actually training of those
sequences here predicting not much at
all it's just the beginning and from
time to time I stopped the training and
I take just my one cell remember I have
just one cell it's replicated for the
for the purpose of training but it's
just one cell and this one cell I can it
has become well once it will be trained
it will have become a language model
what I can do with it with it is
generate a new Shakespeare play how do I
do that well I take the cell I put in
garbage a random character that gives me
an output character for the probable
probability of an output character which
is the next character and an output
state i feedback the output state in the
input and i feedback the output
character has a new input and i continue
and this is a state machine that will
start generating text you see here it's
yeah that's not quite Shakespearean it's
training and it's a bit slow on my
machine I usually have a GPU connected
here to - - it brings me the knife 10x
Peter plus 6x roughly but still well it
has done 50 more batches I will leave it
running let's go and see so here on the
slides what it is so at the beginning it
gives you this as I said not quite
Shakespeare but after only so an epic
what we call an epic is one is when you
have seen the entire training data at
once so after having seen only a tenth
of what Shakespeare produced in his life
this is what we have well it's still not
quite Shakespeare but you see there is
some structure to it after 210 hey this
looks better
it's it's starting to actually spell
English almost correctly and there are
those things in in capital letters at
the beginning that are starting to look
like characters the character names even
slightly less later all look and you
have to remember that this is a neural
network that is predicting character
like character it first has to to learn
to spell English before going to higher
orders of structure so it's still not
completely exact English but it's it's
starting to look like in general like
English at least Shakespeare in English
and you see it has character names and
it's actually inventing new character
names here for Gia in Henry Brutus who
can kill me no seriously who can tell me
if Shakespeare actually used Henry
Bluetooth in his work well you can't I
am giving you the answer and he didn't
but it's a very credible Shakespearean
is character name and this is what you
get after searching a box so it actually
has another title there is a knack that
is a scene after the scene it tells you
where this is happening and look if now
it knows how to put cynic indications in
brackets who enters with whom and so on
it has even picked up stuff like
character names on all caps and when the
character is a function like Lord or
Chamberlain it's only the first
character that is a capital it has
picked up completely correctly as well
and it's actually English so now that we
have this let's try to this was on
slides I will stop this what I have done
previously is that I train this for
actually searching a box and I saved my
weights and biases so I'm ready to just
replay it and generate a new Shakespeare
play let's generate a new one live in
front of you here it is
let me stop it sorry about that
if someone brave enough to come and play
hallucinating Shakespeare on the stage
with me come on yes thank you
big applause thank you please come up
you will have to speak loudly but that's
how it is in a theatre you don't have a
microphone you speak so you can read off
the screen here we we will alternate so
maybe I start and then you do the next
one so let's say enter Bardolph and bolt
the manner of with my best oars that you
shall not see him and we are now to be
the brother's wife and force to be so
many and most great what are so again
what needs thy life then what they do
not dote on thee the word will be at
thee and take my heart to thee and thy
distemper will thou beat me well to say
God save my son thank you so much thank
you that was fantastic
thank you actually I I try to do this
also on the Python code of tensorflow
itself that was fun so in the in the
beginning you had this looks like Python
maybe but very very quickly it actually
picks up pythonic structures like you
know those keywords and its generating
something that looks like like function
calls slightly later it actually
correctly uses the keyword with function
name or hallucination function name is
actually quite invented in the function
name and a column at the end it's still
getting the the nested parentheses wrong
and after a longer while it can recite
the Apache License in full yes it's open
source compliance open source compliant
and more interestingly for us designers
of recurrent neural networks it can
actually close and open the nested
parentheses right to a depth of three
which is quite impressive and what I
find fantastic it has is that it has
figured out how to how to do Python
comments and it's giving me tensorflow
advice in those comments but look it
makes sense check that we have both
color tensors for being invalid to a
vector of 1 indicating the total loss of
the same shape as the shape of the
template I'm sure this makes just as
much sense as everything that I've been
saying since the beginning here all
right and small credit to a gentleman
called Android karpati who actually
wrote this neural network for the
society published a blog about it he
tried it on many different things he
generated a business book for startups
here and he tried to generate an algebra
book in an in in latex actually after
training this produced almost valid
latex so he had to hack it a little bit
to make it compile but then this looks
like an algebra book there is all even
an attempt at the diagram and the line I
prefer is how the neural network solved
how to write a proof look at the very
tough proof or method
that's so clever
all right so that's basically all I
wanted to show you well this is how we
generated so we I take just one cell and
basically in a loop I feed in a
character I take the output feedback as
the input and feed the output state as
the input state and just do this in a
loop a couple of applications of this oh
yes actually we still have a little bit
of time this time I've been using
tensorflow tensor boards to visualize my
inputs and outputs what is my tensor
board somewhere
sorry I'll find it here in the last
session I was just throwing the output
into into a matplotlib which is the very
standard Python plotting library but
there is a tool dedicated to visualizing
training in tensor flow it's called a
tensor board and I advise you to use it
especially if you do a distributed
training or training on remote servers
it can connect to a bucket and and get
the information from there and visualize
it so here again I have configured when
I was training this network I configured
it to actually do training and
validation I put one Shakespeare play
aside for for validation to test my
network and if you remember the session
from yesterday I find it very important
to follow my loss curves both the
training and the test loss curve on the
screen this is what I got and actually
III so first of all who sees something
wrong overfit
yeah and so now the question is why is
it overfitting here I will give you the
answer because you can't guess it but
here I was actually training on a small
subset of the Shakespeare corpus so here
it was over - over overfitting the
of black holes data and since I have
this on the curve I want you to show it
to you because you certainly remember
that somewhere what is it this one
somewhere here I had this helpful
engineering chart which allows you to
you know to interpret what overfitting
is and we went yesterday through the bad
Network we went through too many neurons
we never had a not enough data so I
tried with not enough data and yes it
also gives you this very recognizable
pattern in the curve and as soon as I
train with more data this is what I have
so here the two curves follow each other
closely and I know that I have solved a
problem so actually I was doing this
because I was trying to add a drop out
into my network to make it work better
no it was misbehaving just because of
lack of data Drobo's would not have
fault that all right and and and so a
couple of applications practical
applications to finish we've seen how to
produce a character character by
character model yeah we can also use
this not character by character but word
by word so as I said previously with a
word it's a bit more complicated because
to one hanko the word you need to encode
it on the vector of this time 30,000
components because that's the typical
size of a vocabulary in a typical
language so those are a big big so on
the inputs there is actually a very
simple solution how do you reduce the
size of the big vector well you use one
layer of the neural network and produce
less output it's called embeddings and
that layer can either be part of your
training then your embeddings are
learned as part of the training or you
can use some neural network that has
been already trained typically trained
on the English language
generically and that just encodes words
into smaller vectors there is a very
famous what is it
neural network that has been built for
that is called work - back already
trained available on github you can use
that to encode your English words if
your problem gives this English word has
a small electricity and so once we have
solved this problem of how to input
words instead of characters you can for
example use the regular new neural
network like this to predict not what
the next word is but a categorization of
the sequence and this is used in
newspapers to automatically categorize
articles as the geopolitics science
sports and so on what's very well how do
you do
translation well to do translation
that's how Google Translate works you
tack two of those recurrent networks and
two ends on the first one you apply an
English sentence plus a stop symbol and
then you continue and you ask it to
output the French sentence and what you
have on the inputs there is a choice
normally you should be inputting what
your network outputs but people have
also tried to input what the network
should output so both options exist and
they give you different results you can
read about this in literature so this is
how translation works of course you have
a big problem at the end I won't go into
that because to do the softmax layers
there you actually want to produce a
vector of 30,000 probabilities that's a
bit heavy so there are ways of
mitigating that but that's an active
area of research one that is implemented
in a in tensorflow is called sample
softmax but there are many others
because this is an active area of
research how to do this softmax later to
produce 30,000 probabilities each time
which is a bit heavy
and one more is image labeling so here
is a very simplified version of image
labeling image labeling is you take an
image and you want to produce a sentence
like this is a little girl holding a
teddy bear this is a truck in the desert
so that is actually also a translation
problem you take vectors from an image
and you apply a recurrent neural network
to produce the sequence of words which
you want to be the description
description of this this image how do
you encode an image as a vector well
there are plenty of solutions one of
them is to take an off-the-shelf image
recognition neural network like
Inception and just chop off the last
couple of layers normally what Inception
gives you is categories this is a truck
this is a beach this is a lizard that's
not what you want but all the top layers
are actually encoding an image in some
meaningful way into a vector you can use
that as a fixed end coding function and
input the vector corresponding to the
image here produce this output sequence
and sometimes it works really well this
is what has both generated a herd of
elephants walking across the dry grass
field and so on and then sometimes
yeah not quite thank you
[Music]
you